[MUSIC]
To me, Black History Month is a time for
reflection and
inspiration, reflecting
on the intellectual and
societal contributions that the black
community has made to the world.
Reflecting on the visionaries who rallied
against seemingly insurmountable prejudice
and violence to make those contributions.
And reflecting on those
last along the way.
This month reminds me that
the trials of our present will one
day become the reflections
of our tomorrow, and
inspires me to seek to be counted among
those who have contributed to that future.
[MUSIC]
>> Black History Month is an occasion
to reflect on the struggle of the past
generations for freedom, give thanks
to our ancestors for being brave, and
appreciate the inspiring progress people
from the African diaspora have made.
Without them, walls and
barriers would not have been broken down.
Looking forward, we can learn from this as
we seek to make our future a better and
more inclusive one for
those who come after us.
[MUSIC]
>> Black History Month is a time for
me to reflect and celebrate.
I reflect on the words 'in spite of'
when I think about Black History Month.
I often think about the magnitude of what
Black people across generations have
accomplished, almost always in spite of
something, whether it be adversity or
a presumption of inequality.
Black History Month is also a time when
I celebrate Black people's prevailing
resilience and the vitality that
sustains our influential progress,
creativity, and hope
[MUSIC]
>> Our world isn't perfect by any means,
but Black History Month provides
a healthy blend of celebration and
reflective criticism.
They may sound contradictory, but
I found those two to be a necessary
pair for progress driven by hope.
[MUSIC]
>> Black History Month is a time to
celebrate all the progress we've made,
while acknowledging the immense work
that still needs to be done to get to
an equitable plane.
It reminds us that progress is not linear,
but
arcs towards justice with enough work and
sacrifice.
It's a month of jubilation for
the progress we've made, sorrow for
the leaders we've lost,
and hope that we can and
will leave the world a better place for
future generations.
[MUSIC]
>> Black History Month has always
been a complex time for me.
A time for learning and celebration,
to build a deeper appreciation for
the rich history and progress of
the African American community.
A time for reflection,
to ask myself what more can I be doing for
the Black community?
And to also constructively challenge those
in positions of power around me to do more
as well.
And lastly, a time for
fellowship, to navigate
all the complexities of the month with
a community that is incredibly supportive,
and one that I could not be
more proud to be a part of.
[MUSIC]
>> Black History Month is a time to
remind myself of the sacrifices that were
made by my ancestors, and
the many more that have come before me.
It is a time to reflect on the reasons
why I have the privileges I do today, and
the responsibilities that
are attached to them.
It is a time to celebrate
the accomplishments of the American Negro
ethnicity in spite of the adversity and
institutional challenges that have and
continue to work against it.
[MUSIC]
>> For me, Black History Month represents
a time of reflection about who
I really am, and where I come from.
As someone born in Africa, raised in
Canada, and now living in the US,
I have seen and experienced just
how varied Black identity can be.
We are far from being a monolith.
And yet, we share a relentless spirit
that allows us to not just survive,
no matter where we are, but
more importantly to thrive.
So, onwards and upwards we go.
[MUSIC]
>> To me, Black History Month is not only
a time to reflect on the sacrifices,
resilience and accomplishments
of those that came before us.
It's a time where I recognize and
celebrate the trials and
progress we are making today for
our future generations.
It's a reminder that we
should take time to reflect,
celebrate ourselves and
not water ourselves down.
[MUSIC]
>> Black History Month for me is
a celebration of Blackness, our successes,
our wins, our progress,
our contributions to the world,
our multifaceted and
diverse history and stories.
It's also about reflecting on
our progress through adversity,
while looking ahead to all the work
that still needs to be done.
[MUSIC]
>> Black History Month means
making space to pause,
reflect, celebrate, and connect.
It means acknowledging and celebrating
the resilience and beauty of Black people.
It means reflecting on Black history, and
thinking about what I can do to
shaped Black futures for the better.
[MUSIC]